hello i'm gav i'm dan we're the slo-mo
guys back in the old garage because it's
winter and it's wet out there and cold
yeah let's do something in the comfort
of indoors i really like the videos
where we learn how something works in
slow-mo usually something you just
completely take for granted yeah take
for granted is exactly right because i
didn't know how a tranquilizer dart work
this is a tranquilizer dot there's a lot
more that goes into it than you think
it's kind of a flying syringe that
manages to use pressure to inject into
the animal yeah kind of glad i didn't
know about this at school because if i
did anytime someone would kick the back
of my chair you should be like
[Laughter]
well dan my first misconception is that
there was a hole in the end of the
needle but that's not where it is is it
absolutely not the end is actually just
blocked up and there is a teeny little
hole there at the front can you see that
yeah that is where our juice will come
out of our drugs our tranquilizer or
whatever it is
and the way that you stop that from just
coming out straight away is with this
little rubber stopper
and that will go directly over the hole
to cover it up
like
so
so we've got our needle this is where we
put our
solution or our tranquilizer drugs or
whatever it is that needs to be
administered medicine whatever
and this here is an air pressure chamber
and that is how we get the pressure to
inject the liquids into the animal
because what's going to happen is this
needle will pierce the skin of the
animal and then this rubber part won't
be able to go through the skin after the
needle so it will get pushed back along
the needle
revealing
said hole
and then the air pressure at the back
will be able to exert itself forcing out
the liquid
down through the needle and out the hole
so what drug have you opted for here
we've gone for red food coloring
actually okay yeah so important got a
sort of standard syringe here if you're
actually using real drugs you would use
a medical syringe and like pop it into
one of those bottles you know you get
those bottles and then
yeah pull it out and then we can put our
drugs and fill
a syringe we'll put our needle on here
and we can pull off this part here
we've got a safety cap so we don't prick
ourselves so this part here this little
gray thing you might be able to see in
the air chamber at the back
moves around freely when there's no
pressure in there what we're going to do
is pressurize this rear chamber we're
going to get our syringe again just fill
it full of air shove it in
and then pressurize this rear part here
i'm gonna put about seven mil of
pressure and some seven cc's of air so
now you see the gray thing isn't moving
because there's a lot of air pressure
back up here and that is forcing the
grey thing against the
edge here which is not allowing any
air passed it's called a non-return
valve
so it allows the air in not out last
thing is to add the sort of quill thing
at the back
the technical term for it looks like a
troll doll head it does that's exactly
what it looks like and this is going to
mean that uh when we're blowing on the
back of the
the dart
it's going to cause obturation and allow
that air pressure to build up behind it
so you don't just blow around the dart
yeah it's a fully ready and loaded
tranquilizer
okay so here we are this is the animal
area this piece of faux leather
represents the
the hide of the creature is it called
the hide if the animal is not dead
uh i don't know it's living just skin
okay maybe we've got a thick hide i
think it's a hide okay depending on what
it is
so the light is on the back and we're
aiming at the back so we'll actually see
the needle come through
and it will represent sort of the
interior of the animal the reason we're
doing it this way around is because this
background is clean and the red juice
will probably spray all over it then
we'll come around and get
this angle we should probably also
mention don't try this at home
this is dangerous
oh i didn't do it hard enough
that was pathetic no you gotta give it
more beans i'll reload
i see you've put on your little rod
extension trying to get as much power
out as i can maybe i've just got really
weak lungs well you do have a bit of a
cough at the moment i do maybe i should
cough into it and it'll go flying
oh that one worked
god went straight through
okay before we watch that back
let's get a shot of it going in this
side okay then i can cut them together
so we will we see it all for the first
time but above here like in this area
go for it
oh it's perfect yeah i think that was
really good
oh
i got it there didn't i it's quite a
concentrated stream actually yeah isn't
it quite an abstract look
yeah
rapid isn't it it really is it probably
sticks in there that is 40 times it's
happening i really realize we're in
sloane
[Music]
it's really forceful as well isn't it i
guess because if the animal is moving or
you know if it's sort of an active
animal they want to get that injected as
quickly as possible so it doesn't have a
chance to like knock it off or yeah
and also it's just a factor of the fact
that it's it's quite a wide cylinder
that contains the liquid being forced
through the skinniest needle and the
smallest hole
even
a tiny amount of force would just eject
that for miles that's a good point okay
so next i think we should go
close up on the back maybe try blue okay
i'm going for a different color this is
medicine this time medicine okay
all right i'll be behind you on this one
perfect so what we really want
is it to hit around here
okay
because i've now lowered the frame rate
i've decreased the width decreased the
height because
i mean a lot of the top and bottom of
the frame is unused we're just getting
that long projector like we do with
bullets so we're at 3000 frames a second
now at 720
round here a lot shallower flip all
right might take a few goes in all right
to be honest
oh
that was it
you nailed it
[Laughter]
there you go you just hear a little like
you can do it from bloody close if you
want okay
oh perfectly in fact
geez look at me straight out oh the lens
no quick white white
need a moist towelette you're trying to
put a permanent blue filter on the lens
it's my color
i'm being playing some sort of like
deadly trumpet
lethal bagpipe yeah yeah
it's like a bullfrog oh like a hamster
like a puffer fish like a like some sort
of like chubby hamster
i could think of other situations where
you would make that face it was a bit of
spit
yeah
and the the aim
the targeting was supreme well thank you
yeah
oh it is a fine focus isn't it yeah it
was probably an inch
flip an egg
is not how fast it is that's 3 000
frames a second what it is rapid
we could have honestly done with the
faster camera on this one
so it is about 150 foot a second then i
wouldn't be surprised at all
so it like chucks out the liquid
forwards at first because it has a
smaller slit to get through and then
it's just like
yeah i think the little
little pause in it was probably the
deceleration
maybe the liquid slightly rocked back
because remember the pressure in here
maybe any pull on that draws it back
through the needle so that any sort of
wibblemen might pause that for a second
but look how much you nailed that focus
oh actually that was perfect it was
perfect you can see how quickly it goes
blurry like it's what like a centimeter
out and it's already going out of focus
the sort of hole is nearly out of focus
like the end of the the end of the uh
needle is almost out of focus yeah oh
wait no it's because it's coming towards
the camera yeah it's coming towards the
camera oh
now the thing i've noticed that i found
quite interesting let me just switch
this to
frame by frame mode
okay
now watch some blur there be
yeah at 3 000 frames a second at a 90
degree shutter oh god
watch the plug so it hits
starts sliding but because it's like
rubbery it bounced backwards faster
so it doesn't just like get pushed and
slides it
forcefully bounces back
and then the rest of the needle
bashes it like a hammer straight back in
oh and then it like squishes it squishy
so it's like
oh my god
we only noticed that because we're now
at 3 000 instead of 1 000.
right when you first showed me in real
time yeah i saw something was up with
that rubber plug i wasn't sure what it
was
then you explained it to me by frame by
frame and now i can see it clear as day
yeah but i did see something was up with
it what's happened there
i like that in this shot behind your
blow gun you can see the bigger blow gun
the actual like that
you could use that on a dinosaur or
something if you had to like that's the
t-rex yeah yeah
but you have to set it up for ages and
then like wait for the t-rex to come
past we probably could modify that to
fire this down no you absolutely
if you wanted your tranquilizer dart to
come out the other side of the animal
[Music]
okay so we now have a nice white balloon
with just
plain water inside uncoloured water and
this i guess will represent some sort of
blood system behind the skin if an
animal did have a big
bulge of blood so if its heart was like
on its back yeah so hopefully the rubber
will whip away and we'll be able to see
the color what is it blue yes blue blue
injecting into the water before it falls
okay so you just have to hit it about
here okay
go for it
oh god
you definitely got it i did get it
will there ever be a time where we don't
destroy our small hd monitors have you
seen our videos oh god
that's coming off mostly it's surprising
we don't destroy more stuff it's all
stuck in the serial number
never gonna be able to register this now
i wonder if there's any frames of water
inside the balloon in the air i wonder
how quick the balloon's gonna pop
compared to the bloody crate yeah but
the rubber will be
oh it is you can see it it came flying
out the side of the balloon that's what
that's it
that's exactly the shot i wanted flip an
egg there's some like pure blue drops
more coming down there
oh yeah i really nailed the lens there
oh look it's like catching some of the
you see that the water from the
splashback is going through the blue
stream and catching it
so we're painting painting the the
background blue
mid-air is that could that be a video
where we just throw droplets of water
over like a spurting up blue like
different colors and they'll go through
and they'll become multicolored droplets
i think so that'd be wicked that's one
for the future well we figured that i
forget the logistics of that one out
yeah next up i'm going to try our probe
lens um
no pressure on this one you just have to
hit it within like half a millimeter
b
you know you're talking to sorry i don't
even know why i doubt it
it's good
oh it's not bad though
that's not bad at all
it's pretty good a lot of negative space
but i mean we're talking about
millimeters here and the um liquid is
going up as well yeah into the ceiling
[Laughter]
that's perfect oh damn
what a ball
i love making videos like that what will
you learn something yeah you learn
something and the slow-mo just looks
really cool really satisfying i also
like using the blow gun to be fair yeah
i think i might become a vet just
all right i should warn you though not
everything about being a vet involves
using a blowgun in fact very little in
very specific places would you actually
use the blogger
okay well i'm going to specify that
if i can use the blowgun okay
you just get the gorilla all right
someone else
someone else deal with that yeah yeah
yeah my job's done why do we pay that
guy
i also like how the sort of uh water
comes out of the thing when it's brushed
well yeah it's still pressurized i
forgot
so i thought i totally forgot i'd done
that
oh it's all come out
it's gone to my eye man i've got
medicine in my eye
hold on
that's a good look tony was not
expecting that as well i forgot i
pressurized it all right while dan is
cleaning himself off make sure you
subscribe
hit the old bell our favorite bell
and we've got a second channel too
thanks for watching
did i get any on me i think i did